dr filiz the great dr. Phil yes all
right
welcome to the show dr. Phil he has a
show where he helps people Tom Papa has
a show where he makes bread I mean this
is this is uh this is good friend yeah
this is all of a sudden this the show's
taking a very healthy turn that's right
oh that's right all we want to talk
about is used cars let's not be
responsible here right right is that
really one of your favorite movies oh I
love that movie no one will go with me
on used cars yeah it's one of the
greatest comedies ever done it's up
there with Tommy Boy it's up there with
my cousin Vinnie
I mean it's with the classics right
don't you like when Frank McRae is
forcing him into the car he goes just
get in the [ __ ] our research
team found I've got one of the original
posters when the movie came out what not
a copy but one of the original posters
down at my tennis court really yeah and
it's a they don't make them like that
anymore it was mean the jokes were mean
and a lot of times now comedies are not
mean because they're too afraid of
backlash whatever but that was a pretty
harsh pretty harsh comedy yeah it really
was but it was funny now come on that's
not funny you don't have a sister one of
the greatest things ever done we were
supposed to have Robert wool in here
with you and he did a movie called
Hollywood nights which I loved that's
amazing your big-time tennis not only
tennis my buddy Kurt Fox plays with you
he plays with me
no three four times a week Wow is that
awful yeah it's good right
oh yeah he's good he can hit the serve
about 130 miles an hour
really and he has a backhand just knocks
the fur off the ball really yeah he's
one of my best friends yeah he's a great
guy he's very sorry I just had a great
Showtime special yeah yeah really good
yeah let me explain what's happening tom
is trying to get you to have him on your
show so he can promote his bread show do
you get I mean we're talking to Tom
about how like he was happy that cuz
he's been his hobby is making bread
and he was able to turn this into this
TV show he's doing and now he can come
on these radio shows and talk about
bread and people don't it makes sense
right it's a legit do you with all your
you love movies you love playing tennis
you're now on 17 seasons of dr. Phil do
you know I like making bread yeah cuz
I'd be like if I'm dr. Phil you must be
so tired of doing this show all you want
to do is just like watch funny movies
and and play tennis but instead you've
got to deal with these sane people you
know that's probably the reason is
probably the reason that I like those
kind of movies because you can just
really punch out turn your brain off and
just yuk it up for a while yeah I like
mindless comedies and I like action
movies you know senseless violence
solicitous sex and stupid comedy I mean
that's me right do people always like if
you like a lot of times if you have a
gig job you're a doctor you're dentists
everyone's going to ask you about their
teeth do people always bother you with
their psychological problems and you're
not interested you know they really
don't because I think they don't want to
hear the answer cuz they know that if
you ask me I want to tell you the truth
so it's like you got a question no
cocktail party because they know they
don't want to hear it in front of
anybody else no how do you feel about
the fact that bad baby it's a big like
rapper now she started on your show this
is a catch me outside how about that
girl she now goes by bad baby and she
like performs at festivals and things
like that she's a legitimate recording
artist because she yelled at you and
your audience
how's her music not great but not as bad
as you think
oh yeah yeah I mean look she's got an
audience right sure she's making money
but you've kind of created a monster
time this is your fault
what I'm saying yeah I have to say we
sent this young woman to turnabout Ranch
which is a very serious responsible
place for kids to go to get to value
straight and get their heads on right
and she went and she really applied to
herself she turned herself around and
she came out of there with a good
attitude
and went back home to her mother and
here we are so you think the moms the
problem
I think she's certainly not the kind of
in she's not the kind of supervision
that brings about mental health in her
daughter and they probably also realized
there's a lot more money in in this girl
having problems then there isn't her
being fixed right now right I'll say
this we did a follow up and when I did
the follow up with them I brought them
on stage with no audience and they were
in shock there's nothing to say they
didn't know what to do because there was
no audience yeah and I see as I didn't I
saw you know we're not we're not doing
this we're not this is we're not gonna
be billing playing to the audience so if
I brought about just the three of us
there and 250 empty seats do you ever
lose the dynamics like what did she do
it just stared at me where is everybody
well it doesn't really matter we're just
here to focus on you right well I guess
do you question what you're doing when
like when this girl becomes a star not
because people no not because anybody
wants to see her get better but because
they want to do the line catch me
outside like they want to see the girl
fighting they want to see the girl made
a fool of herself and she becomes a big
star off of your show do you sit there
and be like does anybody get that like
the second half of the show is supposed
to be helping yeah it's not it's not one
of my finest hour she ate you bring it
up do you divorce like hey I'm talking
to them and however they they come watch
they come off you know you do the best
you can at the time and you do what you
can with your heart in the right place
and you know when I was young I've been
at this for 45 years and you know when I
was young I was absolutely gonna save
the world and I took it all on
personally and you know along the way
you learn you know you can lead a horse
to water but you can't make him float on
his back I mean you you just do what you
can
and you make all the resources available
you tell them the the right things and
some people seize onto it and do a good
job in some don't have you had any
interviews where like mid interview
you're like this person should not be on
television you know sometimes you feel
like you're talking to yourself and it's
not going anywhere and when it does I
shut it down you do you're just end the
thing right so when when do you have a
moat like what's what's going on in your
head when you know you're filming it you
trying to help a person but you're also
filming a television show Shelley Duvall
is a famous person and she starts doing
you know that clip that kind of became
pretty famous where she starts saying
that she thinks Robin Williams is still
alive and that he's a shapeshifter are
you going this is gonna be one people
are not gonna respond to well are you
going I don't know if she should be on
television well you know you you look at
everybody we have on as a teaching tool
and there are a lot of people that
aren't there that have family members
they have loved ones that they don't
know how to label they don't know how to
categorize and if they see someone
that's displaying certain behaviors that
are expressing certain experiences
symptoms ideology and you can put that
in a frame for them they go wow I get it
for example we have sometimes
particularly in custody situations where
you've got parents fighting and they've
got the kids in the middle and they're
using them as pawns and they're pulling
them like ropes in a there's a worst
thing you can possibly do but if you put
that on and people see it there are
millions of parents out there going oh
my god that sounds like me I need to
stop using my child as a go-between I
need to quit interrogating them I need
to quit using them to influence I need
to stop popularity contests and we get
thousands of letters where people will
see a custody show like that and say I
get it and maybe the guest doesn't get
it ready the guest will say I don't
think I'm doing anything wrong in this
case
she said but you'll get thousands of
letters at sake she didn't get it he
didn't get it but dr. Phil I got it and
I God that makes it worthwhile get
somebody on your show like if somebody
will somebody write down hey look Sinead
O'Connor or somebody's having a hard
time or will you hear about it the news
and say getting that person or will
somebody contact you or will they
contact you and go I want help
ninety-nine percent of the people that
are on the show ride in and ride in
multiple times actually
you know I think somebody said that it's
an average of like twenty twenty-five
times that people write in before they
actually get through the maze and get on
to the show because there's just so many
letters that come in but then there are
news stories that we'll see if it's
someone that's you know lost a child or
been through something and our we have a
news team it'll reach out to them and
ask if they want to tell their story or
not and if they do then we'll give them
a place to do it and if not we don't is
there somebody you want that you've been
unable to get no not right now but that
I say that having walked in here five
minutes ago I'm not sure what's happened
since then because you know I really
want to talk about things that are
relevant and things that are going on
that caused people to change what
they're doing and like right now I've
been on 17 years it's our seventeenth
season and five on Oprah before that so
that's you know 20 plus years 22 years
when I started the first text message
has never been sent there was it weren't
smart phone rang I mean none of those
things were happening and so that's a
whole new set of challenges now yeah and
so I see these kids now that are posting
up these pictures where they're just
really in compromising situations or
saying and doing things they don't
realize you know what I'm gonna go apply
for a job soon and the first thing
they're gonna do is Google my name right
and it's gonna pull all these pictures
up and they're gonna go oh you know or
they're gonna apply for college and the
admissions committee they're gonna
they're gonna pull that up and go
so they're sitting here looking like
Little Miss goody two-shoes but then I
pull them up and I see these people are
partying down and smoking crack and
doing this and that and it sticks with
them and that stuff never goes away how
do you feel about that culture sorry
time where if you do one thing or you
say one stupid thing on Instagram live
they kick you out of college and it's
it's it lasts forever
one dumb drunken moment and you never
get rid of it I think it's tragic and I
really hope that people that are looking
at that understand that kids have the
knowledge to navigate the web but not
the wisdom and realize that their kids
come on give them a break and then what
worries me too is it's something like
thirty forty percent of kids are talking
to a predator on the internet within
three or four hours of having get on
getting on there whether they're on
Instagram or snapchat or Facebook I mean
these predators I mean they're pounding
on them and they don't know who they're
talking to I can't tell you how many
stories I've done where they have
groomed these kids gotten them out their
bedroom window thinking they're going to
meet a fourteen-year-old boy they get
there and it's thirty nine-year-old
predator with a van with no windows
right right I'm worried about it with my
children that I feel like it's adding to
their anxiety yeah just being on the
phone all the time seeing bad news
school shooting all this stuff I feel
like they have a level of anxiety that
we didn't have and you know one of the
things that is contributing to that is
look all of us are in the media so we're
used to having our paper graded every
day right I mean I get a rating every
day it's published it's out there so
somebody's grade in my paper every day
and making it public that's not for
everybody but these kids on the internet
they put something up and they look at
how many likes they get yeah and I can't
tell you how many kids I've had on there
that are depressed because they put
pictures up and don't get likes or they
get trolls that are hating on them and
telling them you know you're ugly go
kill yourself
I've had these these parents on that
there that there
are bullied to death on the Internet
I thought you're just reading the tweets
that I send Jenna honey I get you get so
much hate it's like after a while you
can't you never become immune to it but
it's like it is what it is I know none
of it's factual a lot of it well you
know we we know that because we're
adults and we don't give a [ __ ] but a
kid who's vulnerable I read one the
other day that said I'd rather have dr.
pepper operate on my dick than have dr.
Phil give me advice how how much control
do you have over the way the show is
advertised because that's like I feel
like a lot of the sort of negatives that
come towards you right and and the
accusations of you being exploitive come
from the ads because the ads are when
it's like we it's got to be salacious
right it's got to be quick and it's got
to be the hey here you don't see the
part where you help anybody on an
advertisement you got five seconds to
show a clip and it's gonna be Shelley
Duvall that or worst or whoever it is
right yeah that's the problem is I have
to say most of the critics of the show
or the platform when you ask them
questions will tell you they've never
really seen the show right they've seen
the YouTube clip they seen the 30-second
ad they see or they just know daytime
television in general I mean on our show
we have an advisory board and it's made
up of the top minds in psychology
psychiatry medicine theology nursing I
mean we've got a head of the family
division at Harvard University Child
Division at Yale dr. Zimbardo professors
emeritus at Stanford University to past
presidents the American Psychological
Association we've got the top minds from
the top learning centers these are the
guys that edit the peer-reviewed
journals in psychology and psychiatry
they're our advisory board and so if we
have a complex show I'm able to send it
out to these these men and women and
they vet it and give me their advice
and we really take this seriously do our
homework but but you ever look people
don't know that do you ever look at the
commercials and go like yeah we probably
should be that I don't know about that
one or do you go you know what this is
part of this is the TV business
commercials are what they are we got to
run them well you know somebody asked me
the other day isn't a lot of what you do
entertainment yeah
and they were saying it kind of trying
to be insulting I guess which i think is
kind of what you're trying to do right
now I'm not trying to be insulting
there is no I'm saying you're you're
saying that's what people do right look
at it I'm not saying you're trying
you're identifying those although this
is a very insulting to I guess that's
what they're yes and no my sure that is
well I certainly hope it's entertaining
because if it's not my mother wouldn't
watch it the reason we put it on TV
right I mean a really good example if I
stand up and say okay today we're gonna
talk about the five points of
forgiveness mm-hmm point one seriously
you know watch that make it but on the
other hand now if on the other hand I'm
talking about a story where mother pulls
in to a 7-eleven in Chicago and it's
summertime and her child's in the back
and she leaves the air conditioner
running while she goes in to get him a
juice box and she's not from here to
there through the window and she's
pointing at the different juice box you
want this one or this one and she's
giggling and the child's laughing and
they're having fun and a homeless drug
guy runs up and jumps in the car and she
runs out and don't know stop stop stop
my child's in the back my child's in the
back and she gets the back door open and
gets the car seat loose but it hangs up
on the seat belt and he throws it in
gear and takes off in the door slams and
the seat belts still hooked on the
infant seat and he takes off
across the bridge and grinds the baby's
head off as he's pulling across and
kills a child and she comes on and says
how can I ever forgive myself for that
I'd rather watch the first one yeah but
you know seriously every mother in
America is now leaning forward and
saying if he can tell her how to forgive
herself for that right I can learn how
to forgive myself for being late to
carpool and seeing my child sitting on a
curb crying when I pulled up I mean that
can help me do this so is there do you
tell a compelling story of course you do
can you ever tell someone though like
how do you forgive yourself for that
like kink is it's hard to tell someone
well you just you [ __ ] up Ryan it's
really it's sometimes that is just what
it is though like why are you really we
only have two minutes by the way I was
gonna ask real quick what in terms of
forgiveness when you had golden voice
Ted Williams the homeless guy who wanted
a voiceover career on your show and it
was your show where you you put him back
with his family and you brought him all
together and everything and he started
pulling out the Louis Vuitton bags were
you looking at him going like I've seen
this a hundred times before this isn't
lasting this is not lasting yeah you
know sometimes the good you do does you
no good no you do the best you can and
you hope it sticks you know oftentimes
it does I mean oftentimes people really
are appreciative they're really grateful
and they come back two years three years
five years later they pay it forward and
they really are appreciative and make a
difference and that's what you hope for
but sometimes you know when you're
looking at a guy pulling out the Louie
Vuitton bags that may not be what we're
dealing with here yeah I mean this we
deal with real stories realize real
people and that's why we show when
people go the wrong way in the right way
we don't just show the positive
everything's light if they go the wrong
way and we get burned we show that too